hi guys I'm going to talk about polyps
and where they come from and what to do
about them okay number one a polyp is a
small tumor
it's precancerous I would say about 90%
of them are benign so they don't turn
into malignancy and 10% do but they need
a vascular supply to grow which is
called angiogenesis and what that means
is that you can consume more cruciferous
vegetables to decrease the growth which
a lot of people polyps don't consume
enough kale broccoli brussel sprouts
things like that very important polyps
are stimulated by two things glucose and
estrogen okay which is interesting
because diabetics are risk are at risk
of getting more polyps in fact even if
they have them removed they have a two
point four chance another two four point
times more likely to get polyps to grow
back okay and that's why even certain
doctors are using metformin to get rid
of polyps
why because metformin is used for
diabetics metformin decreases the
insulin in your body by improving
insulin resistance or type 2 diabetes so
really if you were to correct insulin
insulin resistance you can improve
polyps okay because insulin is anabolic
it makes things grow in the number two
estrogen
women that are postmenopausal have a
greater likelihood of getting polyps
okay and that's because of the higher
estrogen ratio of testosterone smoking
will increase polyps simply because of
the chemicals in the smoke all these
chemicals are called endocrine
disruptors because they mimic estrogen
so we got pesticides insecticides
herbicides fungicides even heading heavy
metals all those chemicals are called
endocrine disruptors and basically
endocrine scepters mimic estrogen so
that's what will cause these as well
because they alter the genes and make
these cells grow more than it should
african-american females are more likely
to get polyps simply because their body
has more estrogen
so it gives them more curve and both of
these estrogen and glucose increase
inflammation and that's another cause of
polyps but it's so funny because if you
research polyp you'll see all these
secondary effects they'll say well
diabetics are at risk or women
postmenopausal at risk or people that
are obese at risk or african-american
women are at risk but they don't get
deeper on why that is okay
it's the insulin and then it glucose and
it's the estrogen okay that's the cause
so if you start consuming more
cruciferous vegetables decrease your
insulin fix insulin resistance and
increase more vitamin D which actually
automatically decreases insulin you
could probably see some really nice
results okay
so I've put some links down below of how
to do that and what kind of cruciferous
that you consume and more data to
support this thank you for watching